personally I love lactose I love that
but it's not not for everyone and I
reckon handle it
hi I'm Nick Gillespie with reason TV and
we are at the international students for
liberty conference in Washington DC and
we are talking to the premier by which I
might mean the only libertarian
chanteuse of YouTube during elektra
thank you Dorian for talking to recent
you burst on the scene in 2010 with the
smash YouTube had a heart Friedrich
Hayek how did that video come about well
it was sort of like an inside joke with
my friends we you were in a high school
at the time senior thesis it had to do
with like Hayek and Maria Montessori and
have this fit together and I was like
stay home on Friday nights and my
friends would be like Dorian come out
with us and I was like guys I got to
stay home and do my homework working my
thesis and they were like oh you're in
love with Friedrich Hayek and I was like
this could be a song yeah yeah and then
it took out from there
what's what's your most recent project
what are you working on my most recent
project is actually something called
party milk and it's hormone-free
whatever gonna be whatever kind boy it
can be like you are lactose tolerant I
personally I love lactose alright I love
that but it's not not for everyone I
don't reckon handle it woo I go pretty
hard you know what what are you hoping I
mean besides having fun what do you you
know what are your goals for your videos
I think people think about different
things you know somewhat weird things to
me like I guess is pretty weird with the
economics videos definitely I think
economics is cool I think it's fun I
think other people can think that too
yeah how did you come by your love
requite adore unrequited for free dirt
hi and the kind of libertarianism in
general um I had a debate coach in high
school that's sort of like turned us on
to the world of ideas and philosophy at
large and political philosophy and
economics and I really I got into Hayek
especially much more than any other
economists or anything because he
emphasizes how complex the world is and
I thought that was like a really
beautiful message he has this quote that
goes the curious task of economics is to
demonstrate to men how little they
really know about what they imagine they
can design and that really speaks to me
I think that's really cool
are you optimistic the to a two-part
question are you optimistic about people
your generation you're in college now do
you think that they are grokking or
grabbing on to liberty and freedom in a
profound way and then but on top of that
are you you know what about the world
around you I mean you guys you know
youth unemployment is at you know record
highs or near record highs the economy
looks bad we're seeing government grow
and grow so you know is your generation
embracing Liberty and then how does that
play out in the wider world I think most
of the people that I'm surrounded by at
least in Chicago and my fears at school
are leftist or like involved in the
Occupy movement things like that and I
think that there's a lot being felt by
people of my generation on both sides
it's funny I think I connect more in a
lot of ways with those and like the
Occupy movement in terms of sensibility
or sensibility also something about like
building something together and that
sense of like cooperation do you find
did they take your politics
seriously though because obviously your
message you're coming at it from a very
different angle or that I engage with
people that have different perspectives
the more seriously they take me I read a
lot of things like Marx and other
philosophers to get a rounded
perspective so are you you know the
world that you're going to be ejected
out into after six or seven years of
college you know are you are you looking
forward to that I mean or is this like a
world where you're going to be told to
do more things to pay more in taxes to
get fewer benefits I mean it is I think
those things might be true but I like
what John Mackey has to say about that
which is thinking about it all
entrepreneurially I'm really excited
about the Internet my generation has the
Internet I
but I mean I don't know I feel like
that's enough right there yeah okay well
that's great we've been talking with
Doreen Electra the libertarian video
artiste what's the best place to see
your stuff you can go to my YouTube page
www.youtube.com/show/fieldsportsbritain